tonight show appearance but three howie
mandel 3d glasses on tonight's show
okay you have it oh there it is there it
is okay so that's the oh
okay this is like at the beginning i'm
carrying the thing in my lap is my
handbag it's in the shape of a hand
handbag so jim mccauley was so nervous
you know because what i learned is these
bookers almost have more at stake than
you do because even if you do great if
you do great johnny goes up to him and
goes oh my god great booking jim yeah
you did great if you die he goes up to
him and goes why the [ __ ] would you book
him so they were always trying to second
guess the host the bookers didn't book
what they liked they booked what they
think
most likes yes and not only and only
johnny not necessarily the audience
because i kept saying well listen to the
audience the audience even if johnny
doesn't like me can't i be on because
the audience laughs
so he said listen and then he started
micromanaging i don't know if you ever
he he started saying what's the set
going to be
and i had to go over each question in
every word and which is really hard it's
so hard for me
especially
and also for you because they're not
jokes yeah
there are things that you talk about
like even my glove if somebody hadn't
seen me i remember i got thrown off at
dick clark show because he goes we need
a big closing joke from you and i go
well i'm going to close with putting
glove on your head he goes i haven't
seen you son what is the closing i said
i'll put a rubber glo i put a rubber
surgical glove on my head and i pop it
off and the audience loves it and he
says
why
he goes
great he goes why that's no we wouldn't
need a joke at the end yeah yeah we need
a joke that's it i swear to you it's a
joke i swear to he goes i don't get the
[ __ ] joke you're going to put a
rubber glove on your head and then it's
going to pop off and why will they laugh
and i said i don't know but i do it yeah
you just know yeah you just know there's
no they canceled me from that wow but
but anyway so he was going after like
whatever questions i asked whatever
things and we're gonna you know this is
set up it was all gonna be panel yeah
it's all gonna be set up so then i said
you know what
i'm here
i'm never gonna be here again
i didn't like the way the way he was
designing what i was doing didn't feel
uh solid to me didn't feel like it felt
like somebody [ __ ] with my own heart
yeah you know what i mean i know how i
want to do it and i know how i deliver
and i know what order it makes sense to
me and you're [ __ ] it up yeah so i'm
gonna do one thing just for me and if
this one thing for me
doesn't work
i go down in flames and i got to do it i
still get to say i did the tonight show
so after i had done all my
prepared stuff yeah i said johnny you
want to see something
and he goes yeah i go do you like 3d
movies and i could see out of that he
was at the end of the couch jim mccauley
is going what the i don't know what this
is
[ __ ] is he doing yeah yeah so i pulled
out those stupid cardboard 3d glasses
and i said put these on this is amazing
and he's going okay okay what is it and
this i i reached into my handbag yeah
and i pull out a little stuffed animal
yeah and i take it as hard as i can and
i whip it in his face oh my god oh my
god
wait wait yeah wait wait wait wait
you're not scared it might hurt him
totally
nobody it's so brave or stupid it's kind
of there is a thin line it is kind of
stupid though i would have done it
if i thought about it i wouldn't have
done it i made the decision and then i
don't go back on my decisions and i said
yes to myself okay and i didn't say no
so what happened so from the moment that
hit his face yeah
it well for the moment i reached in the
bag and grabbed whatever it was i was
throwing to the time i thought it in my
mind i think you can play it's on tape
yeah
for it yeah yeah it it uh seemed like
two hours
i know it would just be like this bunny
or whatever but i had this job and i
would just say after it hit him and he
reacted he actually
kicked the
[ __ ] up the punch line because he did
the punch line he goes this is amazing
it was my punch line doesn't it look
like it's coming right at you all right
you know it was just a joke but he fell
off a seat left so hard and that was the
first set i ended up doing 22 tonight
shows with johnny i did them with wow i
did them with uh gary shandling and i
did them more with uh other guest hosts
but i did 22 with him from that moment
that you're watching right now no so
that could have gone down the toilet
right now after that gym right did he
yell at you afterwards or no
no he thought it was amazing i'll tell
you i ended up losing my time on uh so
after 22 episodes put up the picture of
howie mandel on the tonight show uh with
uh tiger saber-toothed tiger is there a
picture
yeah yeah
there's got to be a picture
do you see it yeah there it is first top
left there click on that actual
so
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i'll tell you about this okay so this is
the last time i did it with johnny
wait what i see is a carrot yeah yeah on
top of a saber-toothed tiger giant
saber-tooth yeah but it's like a fake
one obviously the carrot or the tiger
okay yeah you're right
yeah okay so this is
this is it's not it doesn't start off
funny but um i became the preferred
guest like any comic anytime somebody
was out they would call me he trusted me
i could do whatever i want
and this day um sammy davis jr was
supposed to be the lead guest
on that day he got diagnosed with cancer
at two o'clock in there at two o'clock
in the afternoon so jim called me and
said you got to do us the biggest favor
this is an hour before he says you've
got to come down and fill in we don't
have a lead guest we just lost sammy you
got to come on and i said to be honest
with you i'm at laird studios down in by
the mgm there i'm doing a movie and i'm
off in now i'm just getting wrapped but
i have nothing
i can't do it and he goes please i beg
you i beg you i said you know you're
begging me and you guys have been good
to me i've been there like 30 times
already
i'll do it but on one condition the
condition is
i don't have time to go over material
i'm gonna
just
rack my brain right now and whatever i
come up with you gotta accept me goes i
love you howie i love you you gotta do
that okay so i walk into the i'm on at
the studio and i walk into the prop
department yeah and in the prop
department there's this giant
saber-toothed tiger
and i said uh how much would it cost for
me to take that saber-tooth tiger just
for an hour put it on a dolly
and deliver it to burbank studios
and he goes i'll do that for five
hundred dollars i go you got it we're
going to do that and i need it going now
you got to put that on the thing and
then i just turned to my right and
there's a giant carrot on the shelf
and i said can you tie that carrot on
top of the saber-tooth hike
and he goes
for an extra hundred dollars i go that's
that's worth it yeah so i for six
hundred dollars he ties this carrot onto
the saber-toothed tiger onto that dolly
yeah
i swear to god it was just random it's
kind of like you think yeah you know it
was just random i had no idea and i
deliver that to burbank
jim calls me and says what are you gonna
do with it and i said i don't know
please jim
[Laughter]
you know yeah so what happens is i had
been on 30 times and i hear him
introducing me and they go ladies and
gentlemen howie mandel
and uh the curtain opens and the
audience is applauding and i come out
and i'm pulling that saber-tooth tiger
on the dolly and i can hear the audience
is applauding i get to
that where his desk is is a riser yeah
you know it's like there's the main
floor where the band is and this is this
whole thing the desk and the couches are
on a riser i get to the riser and the
dolly stops at the riser yeah so now i
turn around and i'm trying to lift the
head of the saber-tooth tiger you've got
the front the front tires onto the onto
the riser yeah at this time it's an
eternity there's no more applause
they're just waiting
so
so then i say to doc doc can you give me
a hand doc puts down his trumpet and he
walks over and he's behind me i said
what do you want i said like push with
push and then i called ed mcmahon i said
lift it's an eternity probably three
minutes but three minutes of television
yes on the table
death not only that
at that time the way they have their
cameras set the cameras were all when i
finally got it up on not there but at
the beginning onto the riser all the
cameras were blocked so you can hear on
the headsets of the cameraman from the
what the [ __ ] is that
come out
it's chaos that's chaos and they're
shooting down the cameras are go
what
my phone said something it said it's
having trouble hearing me what does my
iphone have to hear
you're with me all day i'll tell you
later everything that i said uh yeah
anyway so uh and they're going crazy and
everything it took an eternity i'm
sweating ed is sweating doc severnson is
sweating and then i finally got it in
and i probably spent four minutes of
what was going to be a six minute
segment oh my god and it's blocked and i
finally sit down and i'm sweating there
and you could tell just by look at the
body language of johnny does he look
thrilled no no he's it's just been an
eternity of nothing and then he he's
tapping his pencil and he goes
and then i just sat down i didn't say
anything and he's tapping his pencil and
he goes
okay
what
what is this and i go please johnny
i don't want to talk about this
he goes
because
really i said i'll talk about anything
else
nice something that's really personal to
me and i don't want to talk
and then he asked me i could see he was
mad and he gave me like a look he asked
me like one or two questions and i i
realized like i'm in trouble yeah so i
answered those questions he said we'll
be back right after this now i supposed
to do two segments oh no he didn't say a
word to me
the next i i can't remember who was
connie stevens or whatever ladies and
gentlemen connie stevens they took that
away and they moved me down the couch
and i got a call from jim saying he
never wants you on the show again oh wow
and that was my last time on the show
wow
is that a happy ending
good run though
22 22. it's a great one good run it's a
good way to end too it's a good way to
end it kind of poetic actually it's
really the only way you end you know i
got thrown off at the letterman show too
for
15 years
wow but he had me back eventually when
he was on cbs at the ed sullivan but
when he was on nbc late night yeah i
always liked that that's why i love you
your kind of comedy i went to new york
and i was on letterman yeah and i sat
down and i said it's great being here in
new york
i have so many friends here can i say hi
to one of my friends yeah and he said
yeah so i left
[Music]
i went to say hi oh really that's funny
never came back you know out of the i've
been 50 years old i've never been on any
of those shows which one
i did jay leno one time yeah it's the
only talk show i've ever done have you
pursued it
i i'm not gonna call pursue what they
call well the difference is no
nobody calls you in life
whatever is in your mind yeah just do it
just the nike has the best philosophy
just do it if you want to do that then
you should have your uh
agents
call and say you have if that's
something you want to do i don't think
it has the same weight it doesn't it
doesn't so it doesn't really matter and
i think talk shows are kind of very 80s
now even when you watch them they don't
mean anything unless you want to do so i
think i when i did jay leno right i he
called me over the couch i had a great
couch segment
and then i remember the next day waking
up and no one called
no one's ever mentioned it ever well you
just did
i know i just did but no but in terms of
like no like